- It was really important
to me to do well on my GMAT,
after completing an
undergraduate degree in business,
I wanted to complete a finance master
at the London School of Economics,
and then after some years
working at McKinsey,
I wanted to do an MBA at INSEAD,
and for both of these
programs I need a GMAT
and I needed a good GMAT, a good score,
I really needed to get this right,
and with only three weeks of preparation,
I scored above 700 on my first
and only sitting of the GMAT exam.
Hi there, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to my channel Firm Learning.
If you're a first time
you off this channel,
on this channel, I try to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I draw from my experience
having worked at McKinsey
for six years in a consulting role
and now in a C level position
at a German retailer,
and on this channel I tried
to pass on my knowledge
and my experiences with the hope
that this is helpful and valuable to you.
If you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also please subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content,
and also hit the notification
bell to make sure
that you really see every
video that I bring out.
For those of you who haven't seen it yet,
I recently also started
an Instagram channel
where I post daily content, daily updates
for you with little tips and tricks,
what you can do to become successful
in the first years of your career.
In today's video, we're going
to talk about all things GMAT,
as I scored above 700 on my
first sitting of the exam,
I want to pass on four
things for you in this video.
First, I wanna give you a bit of context.
I'm gonna explain to you
why the GAMT is so important
and why you need to do it
well in order to get access
to the top graduate business programs
that you want to study at.
Second, I'm gonna share some
preparation advice, what I did.
I studied for the GMAT that enabled me
with only three weeks
of preparation to score
above 700 in my first sitting of the exam.
Third, I'm going talk about The Economist,
GMAT tutor online program that I use
to help me prepare for my GMAT,
and that I found insanely valuable.
And then fourth, I'm going
to talk about all the books
that I bought, these are
probably the most widely used,
the most prevalent books on
the GAMT preparation market,
and I'm going to give you my
brief and candidate assessment,
which of these books I
found helpful and valuable
and which of these books I just found
a waste of time and money.
Let's start by briefly going
over my personal GMAT learning story.
After I completed my
undergraduate degree in business
from the University of Munich,
I wanted to compete a finance master
at the London School of Economics
and I knew I needed a GMAT for that,
So I did lots of research on the exam,
I purchased the couple of books
and then really studied
hard for three weeks.
It worked out well for
me, I scored above 700,
I was able to get into
the finance master program
that I wanted at the LSC,
and after my master program,
I started as consultant for
McKinsey in the Berlin office.
And then after a couple
of years with McKinsey,
I had the opportunity
that McKinsey offered
to sponsor my MBA.
At first I wanted to redo
the GAMT for the MBA,
because I only studied for three weeks,
and I saw that many people study
for much longer amounts of time,
and I figured if I would
just put in the time,
I would be able to score
an even a higher result.
So, I started learning,
actually purchasing
a couple of other books,
which is the main reason
why this deck is now so high.
But then after a couple of
weeks back into the preparation,
I decided for myself that I actually
did not want to take the exam again.
The main reason was that at the moment
I was working full time from McKinsey,
I didn't have that much
time, and I also talked
to many alumni of the INSEAD MBA program
that I wanted to get into,
and most often taught me
that the GMAT result that I
have is already completely fine
because I scored above 700,
As the GMAT was also valid for five years,
I then decided to not do it again,
to just take the result that I have,
and in the end was the right
decision because I got it.
So now that that's out of
the way, let's jump in.
Let's jump into the first point.
What is the GMAT, why it is so important?
GMAT stands for Graduate
Management Admission Test,
and it is an entry exam
required by pretty much
all prestigious graduate
level business programs.
So both the pre-experience master programs
but also the post-experience MBA programs
to get admitted to them.
So this means that if you wanna get
into one of the globally
leading business programs
on a graduate level, you really
need to take the GMAT exam
and you will need a good score
in order to get admitted to
the absolute top programs.
So, what is the exam?
Nowadays consists of four parts.
First, the analytical writing assessment,
second, integrated reasoning,
third, the quant part, and
fourth, the verbal part.
So let's briefly go over these components.
Let's start with the first one,
the analytical writing assessment.
In this section, you're
required to write a short essay
to a specific question that
you are given then in the exam.
The main reason why
this exists in the exam
is that the business quits wanna make sure
that you actually wrote your essays,
your application essays, yourself.
If your application essays
are flawless English,
but you score really bad on
this analytical essay exercise
then most likely, this
means that you actually
did not write your essays yourself,
but you probably had a ghost writer.
What this means for you is
that this section of the exam
is pretty much only a hygiene factor.
It is not too difficult to
score on the higher segments
of the section of the test
and if your answer's just above average,
this should usually be
fine for most schools,
here you wanna make sure
that you are not raising
any red flags by having a
score which is really low,
especially if this is not matched at all
by the quality of your
other application assets.
Integrated reasoning is the
second section of the test,
here they have different
types of exercises
where they show you charts, data, diagrams
and they just want to
see how when you are able
to draw conclusions from these things
that are presented to you.
The section was introduced
to the exam in 2012,
it did not exist before that
and it is not part of
the final GMAT score,
and for these reasons, it is
not that important this way.
Just make sure that you
score above average,
here you do not want
to raise any red flags
by having an especially bad score,
but usually if you score
well in the quantum,
the verbal part, there should be no reason
why you shouldn't be able to
also score here high as well,
so make sure that you familiarize yourself
with the types of question
that you're able score
on a solid level, but this is not what
will make or break your
application in the end,
especially if you have at least
an average or above average score.
Now to the two really important
and interesting parts,
and this is the quant
part and the verbal part.
As you can see also time-wise,
these two parts make the
majority of the test,
and from the scores of these two sections,
your final GMAT score will be built
the combined score that
can come out of the verbal
and quant section would
range between 200 and 800,
so this is the range of
scores that you can get,
and this is the main
score that you will use
for your business school applications,
this is really the key section
where you wanna score well,
this is the section that
you wanna prepare for,
this is the score that matters,
this is what business
schools look out for.
So, what scores do you actually need
in order to get admitted to
a top business school
graduate level program?
Let's look into the statistics
of some MBA programs,
because most people will
do the GMAT for an MBA.
As per the Current Financial
Times global MBA ranking,
the program that is at the
moment ranked number one,
is the Harvard Business
School MBA program.
If you look into the
official latest class profile
of the Harvard MBA, the
median GAMT score is 730.
So 730 out of 800, and
the total range deviates
between 590 and 800, this
is pretty impressive,
because there are only a
couple of people worldwide
to actually achieve a perfect
800 score on the GMAT exam,
but this also shows you that you can study
at Harvard Business School
with a GAMT of only 590,
which is indeed quite a low score
for such a leading MBA program.
However, what you also need to recognize
is that if you look
outside of the US programs,
the more local programs
tend to have GMAT average
just with just significantly lower.
Just as an example,
let's look into the
best German MBA program,
it's on ranked 64 on the
Current Financial Times ranking,
it is the WHU MBA program,
they do not disclose
the exact average in the class,
though they talk about that,
from their perspective most MBAs schools
require GMAT score above
600 to get admitted,
and just from a bit off desk research,
reading online forums and so on,
I concluded that the average of the WHU
is probably around 650,
so why this is not an efficient number,
you can see that it is significantly below
the top MBA programs,
and it is much easier
to get a score of 650 than
to get a score above 700.
So, how difficult is it really
to score high on the GMAT?
What I have prepared for you
here is a percentile table
where you can see in
what percentile you fall
depending on the total
score that you achieve.
The percentiles change a bit year on year,
but the mean score is 545 on the GMAT.
If you want to belong to the top 20%
of the GMAT test takers, you need to
a score of at least 660.
The score that most people try to go for,
and the score that most people try
to consider really competitive
for the best programs is 700,
and what you can see here is
the 700 roughly corresponds
to the top 10% of GMAT test takers,
and if you want to be part of the top 1%
of GMAT test takers, you
need to score 760 or above.
Of course, you need to be
aware that those people
who take the GMAT usually have completed
at least one undergraduate
university degree,
they're applying for
masters, an MBA degree,
which shows they have
some level of ambition,
so it might be more difficult
than in other groups
to score within the
top 10% of test takers.
Let's start with some overall
GMAT test prep advice.
So, what did I do to score away
with three weeks of preparation?
The first thing that
really worked well for me
is that I made sure that the
time I prepare for the GMAT
is really blocked by that.
I didn't wanna be distracted
by any other activities,
I didn't wanna go to the
university or go to a job
and then only in the evening
be able to work on my GMAT.
I blocked three weeks and
really dedicated myself
to GMAT preparation full time.
This way I put my full attention
on the GMAT preparation
every single day of the three weeks,
and this meant that I learned usually
more than six hours each of these days.
Of course I could have gone
even longer, but at some point
your brain just isn't able to
process the material anymore,
at least mine isn't.
I had several friends at the time
who didn't wanna do that,
they continued to go
to university or to their
job, and then only learn
for the GMAT maybe at the
evening or at the weekends.
If you do this and are
still able to score, well,
you have my highest respect,
but what just I have observed from myself,
is just so much more difficult.
If after a long work, you've
work already many hours,
then in the evening you wanna
concentrate yourself again
and try to learn, try to
get into the material,
this is just so challenging.
If you're somehow able,
really blocked yourself
the time for a couple of weeks
and then you will be much better off.
My second insight is, that
when you learn for the GMAT,
the Pareto principle or the
80 20 rule really holds true.
After a couple of weeks of preparation,
you very quickly reach a certain plateau,
and if you reach that and then
you wanna further improve,
the time that you need to improve further,
will just go up exponentially,
and at some point,
you just need to ask yourself
whether the time invested
is worth it or not.
For me, probably that
point came after two weeks.
After two weeks I started to realize
that my progress really
slowed down significantly
and my strategy was that
already had the GMAT tested
after week three of my preparation,
and if I would not have achieved
the test result that I wanted,
I would probably have rescheduled
to another test date in the future
because as you might know,
you're able to directly
cancel your GMAT test results
in a few minutes after
you complete the test.
The next key piece of preparation advice
is that you show to really do mock tests.
And the one that I liked best,
that I felt like resembled
most the extra tests in the end
was the Manhattan Mock Test.
You can either buy access
to it on their website
or actually if you get
some of their books,
and I'll recommend you
later, some of them,
the test exercise is
already included with them.
There are others as
well, I just heard that
the Manhattan prep exam
really closely resembles
the real thing in the end.
So how exactly did I do it?
So after two or three days of studying,
so after I got the basic concept
of what the GMAT was all
about, I decided to take
the very first mock exam to
set a baseline for myself,
so to understand from where I'm starting.
And I remember that
these two or three days,
I scored slightly above 600,
so it was a 610 or 620
or something like that.
And from then on, one time
per week and sometimes
even two times per week,
I took a new version of the mock exam
to track my progress and
understand where I'm standing.
This helped me to get a live feedback,
whether I'm on the right
path, whether learning,
the studying that I'm
doing is really helping me
to advance my score.
And in fact the last mock exam that I took
roughly half a week before
I took the actual exam,
I scored a 710, which was
absolutely in the range
of the final result that
then I got in the real test.
The next preparation advise
is that while I was studying,
I studied on some actual
real GMAT test prep paper.
So, I'm not sure if you know,
but on the actual GMAT exam,
the type of paper you
can use to make notes,
it's standardized, and it's
not a normal piece of paper.
Instead it's foiled paper,
and you can buy a paper
that very closely
resembles this foil paper.
Here I got a set that I
bought myself that I used,
and as you can see, it has a
special glossy foiled surface.
So of course it's not hugely different
than writing a normal paper,
but at least you should be aware of that.
And I just wanted that my preparation
comes as close as possible to
the actual test experience.
So I bought this prep set,
I will leave your link below
down in the description,
and as you can see
there's these some notes
from the time when I really
learned for the GMAT myself,
so it made me a bit sentimental
when I actually looked at this,
but whenever I did mock
exercises, whenever I studied,
I made a point of always
trying to take notes
and to write on this actual GMAT paper.
And of course it's not only a paper,
but it's also the pen, you
need a special foil marker
in order to write on this paper,
you will be give them
that at the test center,
but I found it helpful to
have already written with it,
to a front ready work with it in advance,
it was no surprise to me at all.
And my last little prep
advise is that even though
it's hard work and it's
very serious for all of us
to get those tests right,
still try to see the fun of it
and the use of it beyond the exam itself.
So, I found that for me
just preparing and studying
for the GMAT exam, that really helped
to improve my quantitative skills.
So, you will take something out of it,
that will go beyond the exam date itself,
there's a use beyond the actual GMAT test.
The next thing I wanna talk about is
the Economist GMAT tutor.
This is a program that I found
insanely helpful and valuable
when studying for my GMAT exam.
At the core of it, you
have an online program
that teaches you all the strategies,
all the tips you need
to improve for the GMAT.
And it also includes lots
of, lots of mock exercises,
besides that, also included
are private one on one
video chat tutor sessions
with some experienced GMAT instructors,
you can submit essays that they will rate.
And one of the best things I thought,
is that they have a score
improvement guarantee
of 50 to 70 points depending
on which program you take.
And 50 points are just huge,
50 points are an absolute make
or break of your GMAT exam.
So if you already took the exam
and wanna improve your
score, they guarantee you
that with your program you can improve
by this amount of points,
and if you don't, you get your money back.
And if you're a first time exam taker,
they would do a basic
exam at the beginning
to get your baseline, and
then they guarantee to you
that they will improve you
at least by that number of
points, and if you don't,
you get your money back.
And I have to admit it's quite pricey,
it's quite an expensive program,
but this way I really
rationalized it for me
that if I do not get
the reside that I want,
I would just get my money back and, hey,
for me it worked really well.
So if you wanna check this out as well,
I have a link to this course
below in the video description
and the best thing is that
if you sign up via the link,
you can get a seven day free trial,
and in the seven days,
you can check out all the
functions by yourself for free,
so you can really get a good feel
whether this is something
that works for you
and that adds value for you.
So let's do some brief and candid reviews
of the books and other materials
I used to prepare for my geometric exam.
I really hope that this helps
you get an understanding
whether it might be worth
your time and your investment.
Let's start with the official GMAT books.
So these are the official GMAT books,
there's an overall guide and
then there are two more books,
one for the quantitative section
and then one for the verbal section.
So these are, as I told you,
the two main most important
sections of the test.
These books have lots of practice exams,
and this is for, I believe they are great.
So if you really wanna
get a whole bunch of exams
that you wanna go through and work with
and this really helps.
And the other plus is of course,
these are the official books.
And the main reason for
me why I bought them
is that I just didn't wanna miss out
on any of the official information
that the GMAT test takers
themselves have put out there.
So I'd say that these books
were helpful and great
if you wanna do lots of practices,
but they' re were a bit lacking
on the really difficult upper
level types of questions.
So my opinion is that
I would recommend you
to get them, these are the
official books after all.
And if you sign up for the GMAT,
usually there's also an option
to then get these books a bit cheaper,
so it should be quite a good deal as well.
There are lots of great
practice exams in it,
just be sure that you also get
some additional material because otherwise
you might struggle with the
more difficult GMAT questions.
Let's now look into some
of the books of Kaplan.
Kaplan is a pretty well known
and famous GMAT test prep
provider, as well, at the time
about two books from Kaplan.
One was the Kaplan GMAT Premier book.
I believe right now they
discontinued the book
and we packaged it into
some of the other material.
And frankly I did not
really like this book,
and the main reason was that I felt
that the material in here is far too easy.
The book claims that this book has quote,
"Everything you need to score
higher" and it also claims,
"Higher score guaranteed."
And I can just tell you that
this book was extremely basic,
the strategies and exercises
covered did not even come close
to help you really ace the higher
more difficult questions in the exam.
So even though this book is
discontinued at the moment,
for this experience, I
would be a bit careful
with the Kaplan material,
especially the more basic ones.
At least this book really
surprised me in a negative way,
so really make sure you
know what you're buying
if you're getting into
the Kaplan material.
However, there's also positive thing
I wanna mention about Kaplan,
and this is in this book,
the GMAT 800 book.
And this is a book that
still exists today,
and this is not the Kaplan
book that really focuses
on the more difficult advanced
students, and their claim is,
"Advanced prep for advanced students,
"master the questions that
most people get wrong."
And yes, I really liked this one,
this one does cover some
great and advanced strategies,
and this one really helped me
to get to the higher levels
to solve the more difficult
problems in the GMAT.
The books that I can recommend you most
to prepare for your GMAT
based on the material
that I used, is the Manhattan
GMAT Strategy Guide Series,
it's a series of 10 or so books
and these books are really great,
because they both teach you some great
and also advanced strategies
on how you should take
the different types of questions
that you're facing with the GMAT,
and they also have lots of practice exams,
so they have books on all kinds of topics.
They have books on fractions,
decimals and percents,
on algebra, on word problems,
geography, number properties,
sentence correction, integrated reasoning,
on the essay part and so on.
So this is really all
the stuff that you need
in order to get your GMAT right.
And the great additional bonus
is, that if you buy the set,
as it also says here,
it includes six free online
exams from Manhattan.
So this is the mock exam that
I recommended to you earlier.
I felt that from all the mock
exams that I looked into,
the Manhattan mock exam was the one
that most closely resembled
the real thing in the end,
and also the results that
I gotten their as a score
were really closely
matching the actual result
that I got in my real GMAT test.
And if you look into the
description down below,
you can find a link to
this book series and also
the other books that I
recommended in my description,
so have a look, check it out
if this might be interesting to you.
Finally, I wanna discuss
another Manhattan book,
and this was the Manhattan
Advanced Quant preparation book,
and from the series, there
some other books as well,
and in this series, there
are some other books
from Manhattan as well, really deep diving
on individual elements of the GMAT test.
I found found that, yes, this was helpful,
and if there are some areas
where you really struggled with,
and if you have enough
time that you've went
through all the other materials, then yes,
this might be helpful.
But personally, I found
that this was probably
just too much, I didn't really need that.
If you have all the other
stuff, that's already enough.
But if there are some areas
where you're really struggling
on, some additional insights,
some additional tips and tricks, then yes,
these advanced books
on the specific topics
might be helpful and interesting as well.
I hope this video helped you understand
how I scored above 700 in GMAT exam
with only three weeks of preparation,
and I hope that this helped,
inspired and motivated you
to also get your GMAT test prep right
and also help you achieve a higher result.
I would of course love to hear about
your GMAT test prep experience,
do you agree with the tips that I have?
Did you do something else?
What are your top tips ace the GMAT?
Let me know in the comments below,
I'll answer every single
comment that you write,
so I'd to laughter every discussion
with you here on this channel.
And if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this
channel to stay up to date
on all the content that I'm releasing,
I will bring out at least one video
every single Saturday for you.
If you want to get even
more content from me,
follow my Instagram under Firm Learning,
on my Instagram, I'm releasing
daily pieces of content
for you on how to be successful
in the first few years of your career.
Thank you for watching,
this was Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Stay safe until the next time.